ne jetez plus les restes de repas à la
poubelle elle les poules en raffolent
elles peuvent manger jusqu'à 150 kg de
déchets alimentaires par an une
particularité qui a retenu l'attention
des élus de versailles grand parc
nous avions en 2011 363 kg de déchets
par habitant et nous ne nous en sommes
actuellement à 3,338 kg donc nous avons
gagné ou perdu plus tôt 25 kg et voilà
notre objectif c'est assez rapidement de
passer sous la barre des 3 130 kg 200
foyers de l'agglomération recevront de
gallinacés des poules de houdan et des
fermières fournis par une entreprise
rhodanienne
on parle sur la poule rousse et la poule
noire cuivre est qu'ils sont des poules
traditionnel un des poules fermière qui
sont de très bonnes pour deux qui sont
les poules les plus rustiques 1 qui
existent et qui sont rodés raf issus de
souche française pour les accueillir un
jardin bien sûr et un poulailler
structure fabriquée par la famille
jézéquel déjà propriétaire de plusieurs
gallinacés nous sommes huit à la maison
et les déchets sont considérablement
réduits en fait il y à zéro déchets
alimentaires qui
et qui partent dans nos poubelles et
tout est donnée aux poules nos amis sont
sauf qu'on est orienté écolo et bien
souvent ils nous donnent des des restes
alimentaires des légumes ou autre ce que
les poules mortes ou de distribution
sont prévues les jézéquel eux recevront
leurs deux poules fermière dès ce week
end